من قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه هنا في
مدينه جده وما زالت عمليات الاجلاء من
السودان سواء القادمين الى قاعده الملك
عبد الله الجويه او كذلك المغادرين من هذه
القاعده بعد عمليات الاجلاء التي تصل بهم
او تكون المحطه الاخيره او قبل المحطه قبل
الاخيره قبل قبل مغادرتهم الى بلاد هي هذه
القاعده وهي من ضمن المواقع التي حددتها
السعوديه الى جانب الموانئ ايضا هناك
ميناء جدا اسلامي وكذلك من الملك فيصل او
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه طبعا هنا القنصل
الباكستاني وكذلك
الممثل قائد قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه
وايضا هنا نشاهد في الجنب الاخر او على
يمين المصور هم رعايه باكستان وعددهم 38
طبعا الان اعداد الرعايه الباكستانيه
الذين قدموا او تم اجلائهم من السودان الى
جده او ايضا من الرحلات التي غادرت من
السودان تحديد البرج سودان الى
كراتشي عددهم يتجاوز الالف شخص طبعا فقط
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه قامت باجلاء
ومغادره اكثر من 500 شخص اذا نتحدث عن نصف
عدد رعايه باكستان غادروا من هذه القاعده
وهي قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه هناك
جنسيات ايضا استقبلتها السعوديه وكذلك هذه
القاعده سواء من رعايه الصين والهند وكذلك
من بعثه الامم المتحده وكذلك بعض الجنسيات
مثل رعايه امريكا والمانيا وايضا السويد
وايضا بعض
دول من اوروبا الشماليه عمليه الاجلاء
واضحه جدا انها لن تنتهي خاصه اذا تحدثنا
حتى هذه اللحظه ان اعداد الرحلات التي تم
تنفيذها عبر هذه القاعده او نفذتها هذه
القاعده سواء عبر طائرات القوات الجويه
الملكيه السعوديه وهي التي تقود مهام
الطائرات العسكريه وكذلك التجاريه تجاوزت
الخمسه وخمسين رحله سواء للرحلات القادمه
من السودان او كذلك المغادره من القاعده
الى بلدان هذه الجنسيات طبعا لا ننسى ايضا
ان هناك خدمات لوجستيه وكذلك خدمات تقدمها
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه من اجل رايه
الجنسيات وكذلك ايضا تسهيل مهمه السفارات
تسهيل مهمه القنصليات وسفرات الدول التي
تقوم بالاهتمام وايضا مغادره رعايه بكل
يسر وسهوله لعل هذه هي الدفعه الاخيره من
هذه الطائره وهي من نوع سي ون ثيرتي ولو
نشاهده ايضا
قليلا هذه الطائره هي من نوع سي وان 30
وهي عسكريه تابعه للجويه الباكستانيه وتم
اختيار هذه الطائره تحديدا واغلب من يتم
او من يتم اجلاءه من السودان يتم جو عبر
طائرات عسكريه تحديدا
وايضا سرعه في الوصول وايضا حتى ايضا سهل
وامانا في عند هبوطها للمجالس سوادب في
وادي سيدنا في ام درمان او كذلك في مطار
بورتسودان لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات